now as we were hearing earlier in the
program storm barrow has been affecting
communities across ireland wells and the
north of england and as global warming
continues to increase the effects of
climate change mean that extreme weather
events are likely to become more
frequent and of course intense in the
future so let me just come to you first
bryony i mean we can't put every storm
to climate change but are we ready
hello uh no you're absolutely right um
you know winter storms have been with us
for forever really but what we're going
to be seeing in the future is much more
intense and more frequent storms and we
really need to start getting better at
predicting the severity of those storms
so that we can then um take action to
try and make sure that we have the least
damage and and don't have any losses of
life um we've got to get ready for
what's in store ahead of us and arguably
we're starting very late in that process
so it's really time we started to talk
about this as a nation
and simon this is a second storm to hit
the uk
in just the last few weeks there's
thousands of people still without power
are we prepared to deal with their
upsets we don't seem to have the
infrastructure in place
yes
it seems that that we are not prepared
for
these kind of storms and more generally
we're not very well prepared for
the impacts of climate change
uh what the kind of simple equation is
is that we can either mitigate climate
change reduce emissions adapt to those
impacts or suffer and there seems to be
a lot of suffering coming down the line
because of a lack of reducing emissions
and a lack of adaptation there was a
report by the statute
three
uh advisers to the government the
committee on climate change and and and
they said that we were woefully
inadequately prepared
for climate impacts
and bryony do you think that people are
aware that we're going to be having more
of these storms and crucially are they
ready and prepared to deal with them do
they know how to handle this
i don't think we really are aware and
it's probably no surprise because we
haven't actually had any public
information broadcasting from the
government on climate since really since
the 2000s and it's been sort of left to
people to find out information as best
they can and i think obviously we've
been a bit distracted in the last couple
of years with another crisis but that
shouldn't really take our eye off the
longer term threat that we need to get
ready for this crisis this is kind of
waiting in the wings it's not going to
go away um the physics of climate change
is is really you can't negotiate with it
so it's in store for us um and as you
know we really need to um see the
government take a lead in helping people
understand those simple things like just
thinking about your home and
understanding how vulnerable you might
be either to extreme heat in the summer
or exposure to flooding or even just
high winds people start start to think
about their homes as not being perhaps
as safe as they once were and starting
to prepare for it um we don't want to
alarm anyone but we also don't want to
have people just you know going into
this with ignorance and we can prepare
and that will help to stop people from
feeling the damaging effects well simon
just going on what bryony just said then
is our government too reactive do we
only think about flood defenses after
we've had floods
and it seems to be
the case uh that we uh see
an impact and and only then start to
think about it and
scientists have given
ample warning of the kind of impacts of
climate change the heat waves the heavy
rainfall events
and we should really be moving fast to
have a public information campaign as
brian he says to help the public
understand the issues and what they can
do about them but crucially we have this
10-point plan from the government about
how to reduce emission how it's going to
reduce emissions but we don't have an
equivalent 10-point plan about how we're
going to adapt to climate change and
what the government is going to invest
to make sure that our critical national
infrastructure and our homes are
resilient for what's coming in the 21st
century
you